in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Trevor
and Jacqueline are with us hey guys how
are ya
hey Dave welcome where you guys from
Kansas City awesome welcome to Nashville
so here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off one hundred and
nine thousand dollars alright and how
long did that take you about three and a
half years good making what kind of
money
starting at seventeen ending at about
140 Wow
that's a big job what happened one of
you get a job that didn't have one or
what we got married okay well there's
one advantage there that's good so tell
me your story what happened three and a
half years ago that puts you guys on
this process well honestly I've been
listening to you for quite a long time
it was gonna stop start thinking about
it for a long time thing and finally
about three and a half years ago I just
got sick and tired of you know I feel
like I make really good money and I
never really knew where I was going or
what to do with you know I never had any
money at the end of every paycheck and I
just got tired of that also I have a
daughter a teenage daughter and I just I
wanted to change her story I when
decided offer an example for her and and
put her on about her path and then I met
this guy who was that free completely
and so 109 was all yours yeah sadly it
was all mine free in it it made the
conversation a little bit easier to tell
him so I have this debt but I also have
a plan yeah so it was a little bit
easier that way okay so you're sitting
there on a date one night Trevor and she
goes I know I'm pretty but I have a
hundred nine thousand dollars yeah in
that it and your dessert had right right
well I didn't quite work that way uh she
kind of eased into it with questions
about income debt and I was actually
pretty fortunate thanks to my my
wonderful mother who I graduated college
without any debt so I never really had
to pay attention to money oh I've kind
of naturally been a saver never really
spent a lot so well then I mean a
hundred nine thousand had to give you
chills when you
yeah it's not like there's 10,000 I know
but just to speak to my wife and her
dedication it helped
mm-hmm to know that there was a plan so
it really wasn't y'all tell people that
all the time and you did it naturally I
want to point that out I told him I said
that dad is never the problem it's the
direction correct and you saw the
direction and she was she had a plan she
was committed to it I'm getting out and
you're like okay I can do this she was
determined she had it she had a goal she
had it all laid out you know with your
plan and I Dave Ramsey was my mother as
a follower yeah but I I since I was
never in debt and money I didn't save it
and pay attention to it I told her that
sure but she introduced me to it and
before we got married she said we are
going to a class oh wow okay but going
to that class talking about it putting
things in motion she was driven so when
were you married how long ago I year
this April okay all right so we're
dating about three years so two and a
half years of this time you worked on
this by yourself in a year you've worked
on it with help yes then yes I mean
financial help yes
mathematical help yeah very cool what
kind of debt was this oh there's a
little of everything it was a timeshare
big chunk on that it was student loan
debt it was car
so mostly those three things so big
student loan debt then it was a big soon
loan debt that in itself was about
90,000 total but like I said I I kind of
stopped and started and worked on it a
little bit before I really got gizelle
intent so by the time I really started
working on it and started making my
number it was what sure what's your
degree in I have a master's degree in
marketing oh good yeah yeah excellent
cool and and what do you do for a living
working in sales
okay cool what about you Trevor I'm IT
recruiter okay excellent
very cool well good job you guys alright
so now you've been married and working
on this for a year your and have
successful how much of the 109 paid off
in the last year
a big chunk of it I would probably put
in the ballpark of maybe 30 a bunch for
he got before you got to it then yeah I
did do a bunch I was very intense and
very tight with my budget and um you
know made people think I was crazy well
you've got you've got a good combination
here of single and married on attacking
this and answering this question what is
the secret paying off one hundred and
nine thousand and three and a half years
dedication without a doubt
drive determination and it like I said
it was my wife who really had that
before I even got around her her drive
to be committed to getting out of debt
is was the key it's amazing when you
decide I've had it what you can do yeah
yeah it really is for me the secret was
it was kind of a combination of things
it was definitely listening to you every
day it's on when I'm out and about
seeing customers and I listen to you
every day religiously and I cannot tell
you how like my daily dose of day would
kind of remote of eight the engine every
time but also wanting to change my story
for my daughter was huge like every time
I was a little bit tempted it was like
no what kind of example am i setting for
her what message am i sending her and I
see that now I mean she's a teenager a
night and I see it in her decisions and
it makes me so happy that I made the
decision to finally change things and it
changed us our story now - yeah really
exciting very cool well congratulations
you two
great job Trevor and Jack Jacqueline
from Kansas City three and a half years
it took to pay off a hundred and nine
thousand dollars making 70 and then 140
after being married count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
that is how it's done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim